president Trump is wrapping up the
Thanksgiving break at his mar-a-lago
Resort in Florida ahead of a major week
both at home and abroad the president is
heading to the NATO summit in London
while a new phase of the impeachment
inquiry begins on Capitol Hill meanwhile
there are new questions over his plans
to end the war in Afghanistan after mr.
Trump took a secret trip there to
surprise service members we Jiujiang is
traveling with the president in Florida
we J good morning good morning John and
good morning to everybody let's start
with the latest developments in the
impeachment inquiry as the House
Judiciary Committee prepares to hold its
first hearing on Wednesday Democrats
have invited President Trump and his
legal team to participate in the
proceedings but so far they have not
formally responded also coming up we are
expecting the House Intelligence
Committee to issue a full report after
collecting evidence for weeks while
President Trump was playing golf at his
resort on Friday chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler sent
him a letter giving the president until
Friday to decide if he and his attorneys
will participate in the impeachment
proceedings ahead CBS News has learned
it's unlikely mr. Trump will send a
lawyer to the first hearing on Wednesday
because it would quote legitimize the
Sham process according to a source
familiar with president Trump's legal
strategy at a campaign rally in Florida
this week the president echoed the
language they're pushing the impeachment
witch-hunt and a lot of bad things are
happening to them because you see what's
happening in the polls
everybody said that's really bull
president Trump broke up his holiday
break with the whirlwind secret trip to
Afghanistan to surprise US service
members on Thanksgiving Day the
president served Turkey to troops and
met with his Afghani counterpart before
announcing the US has restarted peace
talks with the Taliban which once
harbored al-qaeda the Taliban wants to
make a deal and we're meeting with them
and we're saying has to be a ceasefire
but a spokesman for the Taliban
suggested talks have not resumed telling
CBS News the group is open to restart
talks with the Americans at anytime
where it was stopped mr. Trump also told
reporters he plans to reduce the number
of US troops in Afghanistan to 8600 down
from about 12,000 currently serving in
the country though he has not offered
details the president was on the ground
for three and a half hours before
returning to West Palm Beach on Monday
he'll be back on Air Force One
heading to the NATO summit in London
which celebrates its 70th anniversary
President Trump is set to meet with
several world leaders including French
President Emmanuel macron who recently
criticized the president by saying NATO
cannot rely on American leadership mr.
Trump also plans to scale back u.s.
contributions to NATO as he continues to
slam other countries for not paying
their fair share Michelle next week
looks like something we'll be watching
we just thank you so much